From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
See, now these are new. These I hadn't seen before.
看，这些是新的。这些我以前没见过。
Those are big. That one's probably two inches wide.
那些很大。那一个大概有两英寸宽。
The other one's a good inch.
另一个大概有一英寸。
I'm in suburban Connecticut and an 83-year-old man, Dick Paterniti is showing me the holes that woodpeckers have made in his house. For over two decades, he's been replacing shingles and patching these holes. For over two decades, he has been aggravated by their birdy jackhammer noise. For over two decades, he's tried all kinds of things to get them to leave his house alone. Like, for instance, the plastic owl that he bought.
我正在康涅狄格州的郊区，一位83岁的老人迪克·帕特尼蒂正带我去看啄木鸟在他房子上凿出的洞。二十多年来，他一直在更换壁板并修补这些洞。二十多年来，他一直被它们像打桩机一样的鸟叫声所困扰。二十多年来，他尝试了各种方法想让它们远离他的房子。比如，他买的那个塑料猫头鹰。
What I did was I rigged a pulley system where I put a pulley at either corner of the house. And then--
我做的是搭建了一个滑轮系统，在房子的每个角落都安装了一个滑轮。然后——
So about the height of that window there?
就在那扇窗户的高度吗？
Yes. Well, 15 to 20 feet in the air, at the height of the second story window. And then I looped it from one end of the house to the other, going through pulleys on both sides.
对。嗯，离地15到20英尺高，在二楼窗户的高度。然后我把它从房子的一头绕到另一头，穿过两边的滑轮。
He hung the owl on the rope and pulled him side to side, using the pulleys. He did this because he learned, through bitter experience, that just putting the owl at the top of a ladder didn't work. After about a week, the woodpecker realized that the plastic owl was not a threat to it in any way. And it not only returned, once Dick came outside and saw the owl and a woodpecker--
他把猫头鹰挂在绳子上，利用滑轮左右拉动它。他这样做是因为他从痛苦的经验中得知，仅仅把猫头鹰放在梯子顶端是没用的。大约一周后，啄木鸟意识到塑料猫头鹰根本构不成威胁。它不仅回来了，有一次迪克出门时，看到猫头鹰和一只啄木鸟——
It was sitting on his head.
它正坐在它的头上。
So the woodpecker won that round.
所以那一回合啄木鸟赢了。
Won that round. Yeah.
赢了那一回合。没错。
This man, Dick Paterniti, was at IBM for years-- did integrated planning and strategic planning. And when he latches on to a problem, he takes it on with a breathtaking thoroughness. Regular listeners to our program might remember his years' long search to figure out the origin of a piece of music that he would hear when he was put on hold at his local hospital. And he's tackled this woodpecker situation with a kind of "leave no stone unturned," 1960s engineering mentality that got a man on the moon.
这个人，迪克·帕特尼蒂，曾在IBM工作多年，负责综合规划和战略规划。当他遇到问题时，他会以一种惊人的彻底性去解决。我们节目的老听众可能还记得他多年来一直致力于找出他在当地医院候诊时听到的一段音乐的来源。他以一种“不留死角”的20世纪60年代那种把人类送上月球的工程师心态来处理这个啄木鸟问题。
He showed me articles-- highlighted in multiple colors-- about the birds. He showed me a table full of gear and chemicals, foam to fill holes in his house, aluminum flashing. But also metal pie tins that he would hang from strings and colored streamers, on the theory that that scares woodpeckers away.
他给我看了他用多种颜色高亮标记过的关于鸟类的文章。他给我展示了一桌子的装备和化学品，用来填充房子的泡沫，铝制挡雨板。还有他挂在绳子上的金属馅饼盘和彩色飘带，理论上这能把啄木鸟吓走。
Because everybody knows woodpeckers hate tacky [BEEP]. They like a nice, classy house. Kidding.
因为大家都知道啄木鸟讨厌俗气的[哔——]。它们喜欢漂亮、有格调的房子。开个玩笑。
I think it works because of movement and because of the reflectiveness. I've also used balloons, but when you get balloons hanging on your house-- all around the house-- people are saying, what's going on here? It's a perpetual birthday party or something.
我认为这有效是因为运动和反射光。我也用过气球，但当你把气球挂在房子周围时，人们会问，这儿在搞什么？是不是在开永无止境的生日派对之类的。
Wait. How long did you do the balloons?
等等。你用气球用了多久？
I didn't do the balloons for long, but I had them in there for a couple of weeks.
我没用多久，但我挂了大概几周。
His latest idea? While the woodpecker's been away this winter, a hawk showed up in his yard. Hawks are natural predators for woodpeckers. Just hearing a hawk's call, he thinks, should be enough to scare woodpeckers away.
他最新的主意？这个冬天啄木鸟离开的时候，一只老鹰出现在他的院子里。老鹰是啄木鸟的天敌。他认为，光是听到鹰叫声就足以把啄木鸟吓跑了。
So I am thinking now, as my forward plan, of making an alliance with the hawk and seeing whether I can entice him to come more often. Because if he comes, the woodpeckers will not come. So we're working on that as one of our forward strategies.
所以我现在在考虑，作为我的后续计划，与这只鹰结盟，看看能不能引诱它更频繁地来。因为如果它来了，啄木鸟就不会来了。所以我们正在把这当作我们的战略之一来推进。
Which, of course, raises the question, how exactly do you form an alliance with a hawk? Stocking his yard with mice or with rabbits seemed to Dick like it crossed the line into crazy town. Putting up peanut butter might just attract rats. And do hawks even eat peanut butter? So Dick's backup plan, if the hawk doesn't stick around for the summer, is to rig up some kind of audio playback gear and a loudspeaker to play prerecorded hawk sounds.
当然，这就引出了一个问题：你到底怎么和一只老鹰结盟？在院子里投放老鼠或兔子在迪克看来太疯狂了。放花生酱可能会引来老鼠。而且老鹰吃花生酱吗？所以迪克的备用计划是，如果老鹰夏天不留下来，他就架设某种音频回放设备和扬声器，播放预先录制好的鹰叫声。
But it is a terrible sound of a shrieking hawk and a distressed woodpecker. So now, my plan for this spring is going to be very extensive. It's going to be broad-based, multi-faceted.
但那是尖叫的老鹰和痛苦的啄木鸟的恐怖声音。所以现在，我这个春天的计划将非常广泛。它将是多方位的，多层面的。
So you're very aware of the bird. Does the bird know you exist?
所以你非常关注这只鸟。那这只鸟知道你的存在吗？
I don't think so. As a matter of fact, sometimes I'll go out in the morning and I'll yell at him or clap my hands and he'll just continue and just not even pay attention. I'm sort of incidental in his life. He's thinking about food and a mate.
我不这么认为。事实上，有时我早上出去对他大喊大叫或者拍手，他只是继续干活，根本不理睬我。在他的生命中，我大概只是个无关紧要的角色。他在想的是食物和配偶。
Dick's son told me Dick overthinks everything. And the bird doesn't think anything at all. The bird doesn't care. And that's maybe why the bird is winning. The bird's in charge.
迪克的儿子告诉我，迪克把什么事情都想得太复杂了。而那只鸟什么都没想。鸟儿根本不在乎。这可能就是为什么鸟儿会赢。鸟儿才是老大。
Today on our program, "When the Beasts Come Marching In," we human beings think we run the world. We think we've got things under control.
今天在我们的节目中，“当猛兽来袭”，我们人类认为我们统治着这个世界。我们认为一切都在我们的掌控之中。
And then an animal shows up and things do not go like we planned. We have three stories today-- seals and wolves and a moose dropping in on our human lives and showing us who is not the boss. Stay with us.
然后某种动物出现了，事情并没有像我们计划的那样发展。我们今天有三个故事——海豹、狼和驼鹿闯入我们人类的生活，告诉我们谁才不是老板。请继续收听。
Act One, "Beaching and Moaning." And even when an animal is not a pest-- not chewing up homes, not spreading disease, not biting average citizens-- even when an animal is pretty much universally loved, it can still wreak havoc when it arrives in our world. James Spring has this example.
第一幕，“海滩上的骚动”。即使当某种动物不是害虫时——不是啃食房屋，不是传播疾病，不是叮咬普通公民——即使是那种被普遍喜爱的动物，当它进入我们的世界时，也可能造成混乱。詹姆斯·斯普林有这个例子。
A community of seals-- harbor seals-- in La Jolla, California near San Diego. Note that the version of this story that we're putting online and as a podcast includes some curse words that we have unbeeped. If you prefer a beeped version of our show, you can find that at our website, thisamericanlife.org. Anyway, here's James.
一群海豹——港海豹——在圣地亚哥附近的拉霍亚。请注意，我们上线和制作播客的这个故事版本包含一些未被消音的咒骂。如果您更喜欢消音版，可以在我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org 上找到。好了，詹姆斯请讲。
I feel like it all starts with their little noses, so cute. Soft and rubbery like a pony's. And their stubby flippers. Their plump little bodies like speckled bean bags.
我觉得这一切都始于它们的小鼻子，太可爱了。柔软而有弹性，像小马的一样。还有它们矮胖的鳍状肢。它们圆滚滚的小身体像带有斑点的豆袋。
Visitors come from all over the world to watch the harbor seals of La Jolla wiggle across the white sand of a little beach called Children's Pool. It's called Children's Pool because back in 1931, the city built a seawall along a curved peninsula to make a protected cove for children.
来自世界各地的游客来到拉霍亚观看港海豹在名为“儿童泳池”的小海滩的白沙上蠕动。它被称为“儿童泳池”是因为早在1931年，城市沿着弯曲的半岛建造了一道防波堤，为孩子们创造了一个受保护的湾区。
And it totally worked. I played there when I was a kid. I didn't drown even once.
而且它非常奏效。我小时候就在那里玩。我一次都没淹死过。
There weren't any seals back then. But later, in the mid-'80s, when I was a teenager, they started to come ashore at night. Just a few at first, and then a bunch.
那时候并没有海豹。但后来，在80年代中期，我十几岁的时候，它们开始在晚上上岸。起初只有几只，后来是一大群。
One night my friend Tom and I ended up at the Children's Pool after a Wang Chung concert. Don't judge me. It was late. I feel like there were maybe 20 seals on the sand.
有一天晚上，我和朋友汤姆在王中乐队的演唱会结束后到了儿童泳池。别评判我。当时很晚了。我觉得沙滩上大概有20只海豹。
And I sat down next to the small one. He looked up at me and I reached out with my hand and then he totally leaned into it with his neck, like a cat, and I thought, oh, rad. The seals like us.
我坐在一只小海豹旁边。它抬头看着我，我伸出手，然后它完全用脖子向我靠过来，像猫一样，我想，哦，太酷了。海豹喜欢我们。
Then I went away to college to become a marine biologist. It didn't work out. Then a whole bunch of other stuff didn't work out, either, and I moved away. And when I came back years later, the Children's Pool was a very different place.
然后我离开去上大学，想成为一名海洋生物学家。没成功。后来还有很多其他事情也没成功，我搬走了。多年后我回来时，儿童泳池已经完全变了。
Get off the beach!
滚出海滩！
The beach is only 150 feet wide and by the winter of 2010, it was covered with seals. They'd pretty much taken over half the sand and established a permanent rookery here. That's what it's called-- a rookery. It's where they give birth and nurse their pups.
海滩只有150英尺宽，到了2010年冬天，上面全是海豹。它们几乎占据了沙滩的一半，并在那里建立了一个永久的栖息地。这就是它的名字——栖息地。它们在那里生产和哺乳幼崽。
And people loved to come here and sunbathe and swim and take selfies with the seals. And everybody seemed happy. Except for this one group of activists that believe that humans shouldn't be on the beach at all. That it was bad for the seals.
人们喜欢来这里日光浴、游泳和与海豹自拍。每个人似乎都很开心。除了那个认为人类根本不应该出现在海滩上的激进团体。他们认为这对海豹不好。
Some of them wore these matching blue shirts and they had laminated badges. They looked official. They'd patrol the sand, calling themselves docents, like in a museum.
他们中有些人穿着统一的蓝色衬衫，戴着塑封的徽章。看起来很正式。他们会在沙滩上巡逻，自称为讲解员，就像在博物馆里一样。
But they were really there to discourage people from putting down their towels and coolers. They'd tell visitors that the seals needed to be left alone. Then they'd try to shame them into leaving, or at least keeping their distance.
但他们真正的目的是阻止人们放下毛巾和冷藏箱。他们会告诉游客，海豹需要独处。然后他们会试图羞辱人们让他们离开，或者至少保持距离。
Because you're scaring them away.
因为你们把它们吓跑了。
It's OK. It's a public beach.
没关系。这是公共海滩。
No, it's not OK to harass the seals. It's against the law.
不，骚扰海豹是不对的。这是违法的。
That is not harassing the seals. He can go on the sand. I can go on the sand.
那不是骚扰海豹。他可以去沙滩上。我也可以去沙滩上。
The activists set up camp on a sidewalk at the top of the steep steps leading down to the sand. They just had a folding table with signs and flyers and they would yell down at anybody they thought was too close to the harbor seals. They also used video cameras to document people getting close to the animals and then they'd upload the videos to YouTube and Facebook, like the ones you're listening to right now.
激进分子在通往沙滩的陡峭台阶顶部的人行道上扎了营。他们就放了一张带有标语和传单的折叠桌，对着任何他们认为离海豹太近的人大吼大叫。他们还使用摄像机记录人们接近动物的情况，然后把视频上传到YouTube和Facebook上，就像你现在听到的这些。
Get that off the beach! Come on! Let the seals get up there.
让它们离开海滩！快点！让海豹到上面去。
Brian Pease is one of the leaders of the seal activists. But he's not one of the yelley ones. He's more deliberate. An attorney who founded the Animal Protection and Rescue League after he moved here 12 years ago.
布莱恩·皮斯是海豹激进分子的领导人之一。但他不是那种大喊大叫的。他更冷静。他是一位律师，在12年前搬到这里后创立了动物保护与救援联盟。
At that time, there were news reports that people had been seen stabbing seals and burning them with their cigarette butts and things like that. Some really extreme stuff that people had claimed to have witnessed. I don't know that any of that was actually substantiated but this was the climate at the time. It had been in the media that this was occurring.
当时有新闻报道称，有人被看到捅伤海豹，用烟头烫它们之类的。人们声称目睹了一些非常极端的事情。我不知道这些是否被证实，但这就是当时的舆论环境。媒体一直在报道这些情况正在发生。
So the first time I went there was actually at night. And I remember there was a guy who went up to the seals and started just dancing around and just annoying them. And then the seals left. They flushed into the water.
所以我第一次去那里实际上是在晚上。我记得有个家伙走到海豹身边开始跳舞，惹恼了它们。然后海豹离开了。它们冲进了水里。
Flushed is actually a scientific word. When the seals get scared, they all do this sort of wiggle stampede back into the water. Biologists call it flushing. And to Bryan and the other seal activists, flushing the seals is abuse, especially during the pupping season, when the mothers are nursing their young.
“冲”实际上是一个科学词汇。当海豹受到惊吓时，它们会集体逃窜进水中。生物学家称之为“冲刷”。对于布莱恩和其他海豹激进分子来说，驱赶海豹是虐待，尤其是在产仔季节，母亲们正在哺育幼崽的时候。
If you flush them, it's interfering with their biological-- it'd be like if you were sleeping and somebody came in and shook you awake and told you to leave your house or something. It's just disruptive. And it's never an extreme thing, where somebody is running up and they start clubbing a seal or something like that. It's more like this incremental-- people want to-- well, how close can I get? And they want-- they keep itching forward.
如果你驱赶它们，就是在干扰它们的生物钟……这就好比你正在睡觉，有人进来把你摇醒并让你离开你的家一样。这纯粹是破坏性的。而且这从来不是那种有人跑过来拿棍棒打海豹的极端事件。更像是这种渐进式的……人们想要……嗯，我可以靠多近？他们一直向前试探。
And you're just thinking, oh, just a couple more minutes, they're going to flush all the seals away. And you're just waiting for this to happen and you know it's going to happen. And it always does happen.
你就想，哦，再过几分钟，他们就会把所有的海豹赶走。你就等着这一刻发生，你知道它一定会发生。而且确实总是发生。
Here they go.
它们要走了。
Boo.
嘘。
Here they go.
它们要走了。
You're harassing the seals.
你在骚扰海豹。
Flushing the seals is also illegal. It's a violation of the Marine Mammal Protection Act, a federal law that prohibits the hunting and harassment of any marine mammal. That part about harassment, though, is where interpretations seem to vary. Because when the seals flushed, they always came back. The harbor seal rookery here was thriving.
驱赶海豹也是违法的。这违反了《海洋哺乳动物保护法》，这是一项禁止捕猎和骚扰任何海洋哺乳动物的联邦法律。然而，关于骚扰的那部分，解释似乎有所不同。因为当海豹被赶走时，它们总是会回来。这里的港海豹栖息地欣欣向荣。
Most people liked the seals. Locals had been sharing this beach with them for 20 years. But now these activists were walking around with megaphones, telling everybody that they couldn't be down on the sand or in the water, yelling. And if anybody disagreed with the activists or their methods, they were branded seal haters.
大多数人喜欢海豹。当地人已经和它们共享这个海滩20年了。但现在这些激进分子拿着扩音器到处走，告诉每个人他们不能待在沙滩上或水里，大声叫喊。如果有人不同意激进分子及其方法，就会被贴上“讨厌海豹者”的标签。
Some of the locals began to talk about how to best handle this. They decided to form their own group, set up their own tables at the beach with their own flyers and banners. Their goal in all of this was just to make sure that the beach stayed open to people, that they could keep sharing it with the seals. And these newly minted "shared use" advocates-- they were done taking orders from the seal activists. So if you happened to show up at the beach on a Saturday with your kids and a picnic basket, you would see the two opposing sides-- pro-seal and shared use. And they were ready to rumble.
一些当地人开始讨论如何最好地处理这个问题。他们决定成立自己的小组，在海滩上摆放自己的桌子，贴上自己的传单和横幅。他们这一切的目标只是为了确保海滩对公众开放，人们可以继续与海豹共享。这些新加入的“共享利用”拥护者——他们受够了听从激进分子的指挥。所以如果你碰巧在周六带着孩子和野餐篮来到海滩，你会看到两个对立的阵营——支持海豹派和共享利用派。他们随时准备大干一场。
The city council actually voted to close this beach during pupping season, which is--
市议会实际上投票决定在产仔季节关闭这个海滩，这……
This is that pro-seal attorney guy, Bryan Pease.
这就是那个支持海豹派的律师，布莱恩·皮斯。
And you can make donations. You can sign up for our email list. You can buy a t-shirt or a seal toy. All these other booths that are set up here are either here just to make money-- that's the tie-dye booth. Or, in the case of this booth in the corner over here, are actually here to oppose the seals.
你可以捐款。你可以注册我们的邮件列表。你可以买一件T恤或一个海豹玩具。这里设立的所有其他摊位要么只是为了赚钱——那是扎染摊位。要么，就像角落里的这个摊位一样，实际上是在反对海豹。
We're opposing you.
我们是在反对你们。
They're selling--
他们卖的是……
We're opposing you.
我们是在反对你们。
You know you sound stupid.
你知道你听起来很蠢吗。
We're opposing you.
我们是在反对你们。
That is so stupid.
那真是太蠢了。
We are opposing you.
我们是在反对你们。
Look at you. Look how stupid you look.
看看你。看看你看起来有多蠢。
This is how it usually went down. Talking led to yelling and the yelling led to just a cacophonous din of outrage. It seemed like everybody in San Diego took a hard-line stance and they all fell into one of these two camps.
事情通常就是这样发展的。谈话变成叫喊，叫喊变成愤怒的嘈杂声。似乎圣地亚哥的每个人都采取了强硬立场，他们都落入了这两个阵营中的一个。
Both sides dished out a lot of propaganda. The shared use people would say that the seals were never in any jeopardy-- that the activists' crusade was nothing but an elaborate scam. Here's a shared use guy talking into the camera of a seal activist.
双方都散布了大量的宣传。共享利用派会说海豹从来没有任何危险——激进分子的运动不过是一场精心策划的骗局。这是一位共享利用派的人对着海豹激进分子的摄像机说话。
What are you saving them from? No response. What are you saving him from? This is a seal "crookery," as far as I'm concerned. You are here stealing money from tourists. You're conning them out of their hard-earned money that they come here on vacation with. And claiming to say that you're saving seals.
你在从它们手中拯救什么？没回应。你在从它们手中拯救他什么？据我看来，这是一个海豹“敲诈屋”。你在这里从游客那里骗钱。你骗取他们辛苦赚来的度假钱。然后声称你在拯救海豹。
This was a common claim made by the shared use people-- that the whole pro-seal movement was just a way to rake in a bunch of cash. Bryan Pease, the pro-seal guy who started the Animal Protection and Rescue League, says that the money collected through donations was barely enough to hire a nighttime security guard.
这是共享利用派常用的说法——整个支持海豹运动只是一种敛财方式。布莱恩·皮斯，那个发起动物保护与救援联盟的支持海豹人士，说捐款收集到的钱勉强够雇一个夜间保安。
But the other part is kind of true. The seals were not endangered. In fact, on the International List of Threatened Species, harbor seals are classified as a species of least concern-- the exact same designation that's given to the common pigeon and to the house rat.
但另一部分是真的。海豹并没有濒临灭绝。事实上，在国际受威胁物种名单上，港海豹被归类为“无危物种”——这与普通鸽子和家鼠的定级完全一样。
But the rallying chant of most seal activists was that shared use is abuse-- any shared use. And that the shared use people were animal haters-- that they just wanted the seals gone. But if you actually talked to a shared use advocate, they'd tell you something different.
但大多数海豹激进分子的口号是“共享利用就是虐待”——任何共享利用都是。并且共享利用派是“动物仇恨者”——他们只是想把海豹赶走。但如果你真的和一位共享利用拥护者谈过，他们会告诉你不同的事情。
Oh, I never had any problems with the seals. I never had any problems with the seals.
哦，我从来没有和海豹有过任何问题。我从来没有和海豹有过任何问题。
This is Kent Trego. He's a consultant at Coastal Environments and he started a research based organization called the Nautilus Oceanic Institute. He's published more than 50 scientific papers. He also swam at the Children's Pool as a kid back in the 1960s. He's been sort of a voice of reason for the shared use side.
这位是肯特·特雷戈。他是沿海环境公司的顾问，并创办了一个名为“鹦鹉螺海洋研究所”的研究型组织。他发表了50多篇科学论文。他小时候在20世纪60年代也曾在儿童泳池游泳。他一直是共享利用派的理性之声。
Everybody that I know likes the animals. The divers enjoy swimming with them. But they're making a fuss for whatever.
我认识的每个人都喜欢这些动物。潜水员喜欢和它们一起游泳。但他们无缘无故地小题大做。
The seal activists, he means.
他是指海豹激进分子。
And they're disturbing the peace. They're violating people's civil rights by harassing them in a public area. Tourist stuff-- they don't want to listen to that. They don't want to hear that. They don't want kids seeing that.
他们在破坏和平。他们通过在公共区域骚扰他人来侵犯公民权利。旅游业的东西——他们不想听。他们不想听那个。他们不想让孩子看到那个。
You could draw a similar situation and a similar argument. Let's say there is a public park you took your kids to and somebody came along and said, you people can't be here. This is the rare something-something ground squirrel habitat and you're bothering them.
你可以引出一个类似的情况和类似的论点。假设有一个你带孩子去的公园，有人过来对你说，你们不能待在这里。这是珍稀的某某地松鼠栖息地，你在打扰它们。
You'd probably go, are you out of your mind? This is a public park. Maybe there is an issue, but they're spewing all this and being antagonistic towards you or your kids.
你可能会说，你疯了吗？这是一个公共公园。也许确实存在问题，但他们喷着这些话并对你或你的孩子表现出敌意。
Down there-- one day I was there. I was talking to this one guy and this little girl. She's got to be six. His daughter comes around crying. And she said, that man came after me. She points to this guy--
在下面——有一天我在那儿。我正和一个家伙谈话，还有一个小女孩。她才六岁。他的女儿哭着跑过来。她说，那个男人追我。她指着这个家伙……
A pro-seal activist.
一个支持海豹的激进分子。
This guy-- he's running up the beach and says, keep your kid away from seals. I'm watching this and I'm going, who the hell is this guy? The father is incensed and he's yelling at the guy, what are doing around my daughter?
这个家伙——他跑过沙滩说，让你的孩子离海豹远点。我看着这一幕，想，这家伙到底是谁？父亲被激怒了，对着那人喊，你在我女儿周围干什么？
And she was-- she was terrified. She was screaming. It was that kind of incident where it just shocks you. You don't see that thing. And there's a guy chasing a child?
她当时……她吓坏了。她在尖叫。就是那种让你震惊的事件。你没见过那种场面。有个家伙在追赶一个孩子？
There were definitely times when you'd see kids in the videos walk right up to the seals and try to pet them. And the pro-seal activists would lose their minds.
确实有几次你会看到视频里的孩子径直走到海豹身边试图抚摸它们。而支持海豹的激进分子会疯掉。
Get your kid in check! Whoever's kid is in the pink! Keep them away from the seals!
管好你的孩子！穿粉色衣服那个孩子的家长！让它们离海豹远点！
Relax.
放松点。
As the years dragged on, more and more of these confrontations were ending up in court. And Bryan Pease began to spend a lot of his time there defending pro-seal activists who'd been arrested or had been issued citations. He was also bringing civil cases against the other side-- shared use advocates who'd been arrested during confrontations with pro-seal folks.
随着时间的推移，越来越多的这种对抗最终上了法庭。布莱恩·皮斯开始花大量时间在那里为被逮捕或被传唤的支持海豹的激进分子辩护。他还对另一方提起民事诉讼——在与支持海豹派的冲突中被逮捕的共享利用拥护者。
At a certain point, he stopped going to the Children's Pool altogether. He says it just stressed him out too much.
到了某个时候，他完全停止去儿童泳池了。他说这让他压力太大。
I tried to stay out of most of it. Sometimes I'd be down there, but generally, it's not very productive to be engaging in shouting matches with people that just don't agree with you. It's why they call it the Children's Pool because it's where adults go to act like children.
我试着不参与大部分事情。有时我会去那里，但总的来说，和那些不同意你的人进行叫嚣并没有什么成效。这就是为什么它被称为“儿童泳池”，因为那是成年人去像孩子一样行事的地方。
Kent Trego, our marine sciencey, shared use guy, didn't engage in all the fighting, either. He just tried to educate the public with a little logic and some biology 101. And he went about it in sort of a quaint, bygone way that he hoped might rise above the shouts of the angry mob. He wrote letters to the local editors. The papers printed the letters with Kent's name and his title. And then the hate mail started to roll in-- threatening phone calls and emails-- by Kent's count, more than 200 of them.
肯特·特雷戈，我们的海洋科学派、共享利用派的朋友，也没有参与所有的争斗。他只是试图用一点逻辑和生物学常识来教育公众。他以一种他希望能够超越愤怒人群叫喊的古朴的、过时的方式去做。他写信给当地编辑。报纸刊登了信件，附上了肯特的名字和头衔。然后仇恨邮件开始涌入——威胁电话和电子邮件——据肯特统计，有200多封。
Were they anonymous or did they--
它们是匿名的还是……
Yeah, they were anonymous. We know who you are. We know you want to get rid of the seals. That's what people would say to me. That's what certain people would say to me.
是的，它们是匿名的。我们知道你是谁。我们知道你想赶走海豹。人们会这样对我说。某些人会这样对我说。
We know you're in a plot and that the city's involved. I don't know if they're kidding or if they got problems-- if they're drunk. If they're on drugs. I don't know.
我们知道你有一个阴谋，而且城市也参与其中。我不知道他们是开玩笑还是有问题——如果他们喝醉了。如果他们嗑药了。我不知道。
How did you respond to that?
你怎么回应？
You don't respond. You don't-- you're not supposed to-- what I was told by my attorney and other people-- you don't talk to those people. If there's an incident like that, you report it to the police. And the police got called a lot. And then they get tired of coming down there.
你不要回应。你不……你不应该……我的律师和其他人是这么告诉我的——不要和那些人说话。如果发生那种事件，你就报警。警察被叫去很多次。然后他们也厌倦了去那里。
At the height of the conflict in 2013, the San Diego police department responded to 227 calls at the Children's Pool. And it seems like neither camp was really consulting the dictionary before they tossed around words like abuse and harassment and assault. In one video, a cop arrives on the scene to find a shared use lady in her 60s and a Middle Eastern guy holding a skateboard and a camera.
在2013年冲突最激烈的时候，圣地亚哥警察局在儿童泳池接到了227个报警电话。似乎在双方抛出“虐待”、“骚扰”和“人身攻击”这些词汇之前，都没有查过字典。在一段视频中，警察赶到现场，发现一位60多岁的共享利用派女士和一个拿着滑板和相机的中东男子。
The lady's saying that the seal activists are blocking her from sitting on a bench. And the skater's filming it and she just glancingly brushes the camera away. And the cop's watching all this happen.
女士说海豹激进分子阻止她坐在长椅上。滑板手在拍视频，她只是轻蔑地挥手把相机拨开。警察看着这一切发生。
Don't touch me. You touch me.
别碰我。你碰了我。
Ma'am, if you assault him--
女士，如果你袭击他……
She touched me.
她碰了我。
You can't--
你不能……
Sir, she touched me.
先生，她碰了我。
Yeah, I saw that. And it was-- I know it was brutal. I know the way she touched you was brutal. You're in pain.
是的，我看到了。而且……我知道很残暴。我知道她碰你的方式很残暴。你很痛苦。
That's the cop. He's being sarcastic.
那是警察。他在讽刺。
Yes, I am in pain.
是的，我很痛苦。
You're doing fine. Now just try to relax there.
你做得很好。现在试着放松一下。
I'm trying.
我在尝试。
Just relax.
放松点。
I'm trying.
我在尝试。
I touched his arm to get the camera out of my face. I find it very intimidating to have a camera in my face.
我碰了他的手臂只是为了让他把相机从我脸上移开。有台相机对着我的脸让我感到非常受威胁。
The cop, at this point, has had enough.
警察此时已经受够了。
This is all very childish, in my opinion. It really is. It's very childish.
在我看来，这一切都很幼稚。真的。非常幼稚。
It's a loss. Give up.
这是一个损失。放弃吧。
I said very childish. Have you got that on camera?
我说非常幼稚。你录下来了吗？
Everybody was filming everybody. It was like a stand off with camcorders and cell phones. A bunch of videos just show a close up of a face holding a video camera pointing right back, filling the frame. It's like the worst art film of all time. Like in this video, a shared use guy is being all pushy with his camera.
每个人都在拍每个人。这就像一场带着摄像机和手机的僵持。很多视频只显示一张脸拿着摄像机对着镜头，填满了画面。就像有史以来最烂的艺术电影。就像在这个视频里，一个共享利用派的人拿着摄像机咄咄逼人。
Can you say what you just said out loud? Why do you talk under your breath?
你能把你刚才说的话大声说出来吗？你为什么在嘴里嘀咕？
Why don't you stop intimidating her?
你为什么不停止恐吓她？
Why do you talk under your breath?
你为什么在嘴里嘀咕？
Why don't you stop intimidating her?
你为什么不停止恐吓她？
Can you please stay--
你能离远点吗……
Speak a bit louder so I can get a recording.
大声点，这样我才能录下来。
Could you please stay back from me? I really feel like you're invading my privacy right now.
你能离我远点吗？我真的觉得你现在侵犯了我的隐私。
Stay back. You're annoying us and invading our privacy and I'm asking you politely now to move away.
离远点。你在骚扰我们，侵犯我们的隐私，我现在礼貌地要求你走开。
You're almost touching me. You're less than a foot away.
你快碰到我了。你离我不到一英尺。
I'm just here to record what she's telling the public.
我只是来记录她对公众说的话。
The two sides became so fixated on their hatred for each other that in a lot of videos, they don't even mention the seals. One morning, it's cold and foggy on the beach, and a 70-year-old pro-seal activist just has had enough of a shared use guy who's filming her and she charges right up to his camera.
双方变得如此沉迷于对彼此的仇恨，以至于在许多视频中，他们甚至不提海豹。一天早晨，海滩上又冷又雾，一位70岁的支持海豹激进分子终于受够了一个正在拍她的共享利用派男士，她冲着他的相机冲了过去。
So you're spitting on me now, huh? That's battery.
所以你现在对我吐口水了，哈？那是人身攻击。
I didn't touch you.
我没碰你。
You spit on me.
你对我吐口水了。
You're harassing me.
你在骚扰我。
You spit on me.
你对我吐口水了。
I did. I spit on your camera.
我确实吐了。我吐在你的相机上了。
No, you spit on me right in the forehead.
不，你直接吐在我前额上了。
Poor boy.
可怜的男孩。
At a certain point, the factions had been battling so long that they knew each other by name, knew where each other lived and worked. And the attacks were becoming more personal, the threats more vicious.
到了某个时候，两派已经斗争了太久，以至于他们知道了对方的名字，知道对方住在哪儿、在哪儿工作。攻击变得更加个人化，威胁也更加恶毒。
Back away from us right now, you disgusting little turd.
现在就从我们身边退开，你这个恶心的脏东西。
And you're a fucking bitch.
你是个该死的婊子。
Piss off.
滚开。
And somebody needs to fucking kill you.
有人需要杀了你。
Yeah? Want to kill me? Why don't you give it a try? Why don't you give it a try?
是吗？想杀我？你为什么不试试？你为什么不试试？
Don't let me catch you in an alley some time.
别让我在小巷里逮到你。
Oh, really? How about it?
哦，真的吗？怎么样？
People on the shared use side had always accused the seal activists of valuing the lives of animals over people. And now, the sentiment began to ring more true. This one's a little hard to hear.
共享利用派的人一直指责海豹激进分子视动物生命重于人命。现在，这种情绪变得更加真实了。这一段有点难听清。
Don't get too close to the seals or I'll make your life miserable.
别离海豹太近，否则我会让你的生活变得很痛苦。
He said, "don't get too close to the seals or I'll make your life miserable."
他说，“别离海豹太近，否则我会让你的生活变得很痛苦。”
I'll bring my guns here.
我会带枪来这里。
"I'll bring my guns here."
“我会带枪来这里。”
I'll fuck you all up.
我会干掉你们所有人。
And "I'll fuck you all up." Throughout this war, the pro-seal camp had a unique weapon on their side-- the power of the federal government. And at some point, they really began to brandish it. The feds could arrest or issue citations to anyone who violates the Marine Mammal Protection Act. So the seal activists would film people as they harassed the seals or drove them from the beach.
还有“我会干掉你们所有人”。在这场战争中，支持海豹阵营有一件独特的武器——联邦政府的力量。在某种程度上，他们真的开始挥舞这件武器。联邦当局可以逮捕或传唤任何违反《海洋哺乳动物保护法》的人。所以海豹激进分子会拍摄人们骚扰海豹或将它们赶出海滩的过程。
These are the lads that went for the swim.
这些是去游泳的家伙。
And then they would keep the camera rolling and they'd get all shaky--
然后他们会一直开着相机，变得非常抖动……
Cover your license plate.
拍下他的车牌。
--as they chased the lawbreakers all the way back to their car.
……当他们追着违法者回到车上时。
Cover your license plate.
拍下他的车牌。
--to record their license plate.
……记录他们的车牌。
Oh, I got it.
哦，我拍到了。
And then when they had it, the activists would turn over the video to the National Marine Fisheries Service and the feds would issue fines of $500 to anybody who made the seals flush. It was an incident like this one that brought the seal war to one of its darkest hours.
拿到车牌后，激进分子会把视频交给国家海洋渔业局，联邦当局会向任何导致海豹受到惊吓的人处以500美元的罚款。正是这样的事件将海豹战争带向了它最黑暗的时刻之一。
You really want me to read this?
你真的想让我读这个？
Read this all.
把整个读出来。
I guess I was the first one who read it.
我想我是第一个读到它的。
One day, Bryan Pease received an email that was addressed to one of his volunteers. It was a threat. The volunteer, a young woman who's identified only as "witness" in the federal court documents, had filmed the license plate of a pair of scuba divers who'd flushed some seals when they came up on the beach. Bryan read me the email.
一天，布莱恩·皮斯收到了一封发给他其中一名志愿者的邮件。那是一个威胁。这名志愿者，在联邦法院文件中仅被称为“目击者”的年轻女子，拍摄了一对在海滩上驱赶海豹的水肺潜水员的车牌。布莱恩给我读了这封邮件。
OK. "Two divers that used the Children's Pool in September have been cited by federal wildlife marshals for disturbing the seals. Witness was apparently the one who turned them in. The problem is, now, that revenge will be taken out on witness."
好的。“9月份在儿童泳池使用的两名潜水员已被联邦野生动物警长以骚扰海豹为由传唤。显然是目击者举报了他们。问题是，现在，报复将落在目击者身上。”
The email continues, "Many of the local divers have close friends in the California motorcycle clubs. Motorcycle club members have been contacted about witness and she will be dealt with very harshly, if she is not killed. They know that if she's not in San Diego, she may be found in San Francisco.
邮件继续写道，“当地许多潜水员与加州摩托车俱乐部有密切联系。摩托车俱乐部成员已被联络，目击者将受到严厉对付，如果不被杀死的话。他们知道，如果她不在圣地亚哥，她可能在旧金山被找到。”
Either San Diego or Oakland hit hogs will be involved in her punishment. She's brought this on herself." And then it's signed "Biker Bobbie," with an I-E. Probably the least threatening Hell's Angels nickname of all time, but still.
“圣地亚哥或奥克兰的恶棍将参与对她的惩罚。这是她自找的。”结尾署名是“Biker Bobbie”，拼写是I-E。可能是地狱天使有史以来最不具威胁性的绰号了，但依然如此。
Was your coll-- was the woman who was threatened-- was she scared?
你的同事……那个被威胁的女子……她害怕吗？
Oh, she was terrified. Yeah. And I know her mother, who is also involved in the pro-seal protection campaign. And she had said that they were-- their whole family was scared for quite a while. So it was pretty serious.
哦，她吓坏了。是的。我认识她的母亲，她也参与了支持海豹保护运动。她说她们……全家人吓坏了好长一段时间。所以这相当严重。
Biker Bobbie emailed two other threats to the Animal Protection and Rescue League. In one, he threatened to burn down the organization's storefront and to bomb a coffee shop. Bryan Pease turned the emails over to authorities.
Biker Bobbie向动物保护与救援联盟发了两封威胁邮件。在其中一封里，他威胁要烧毁该组织的店面并炸掉一家咖啡馆。布莱恩·皮斯将这些邮件交给了当局。
The female volunteer-- the one who was singled out with the death threat-- the one who'd sent the video of the two scuba divers to the National Marine Fisheries Service-- she was considered a federal witness. And threatening a federal witness is a federal crime so the FBI got involved. They tracked the email sender's IP address to a public library about five blocks away from the Children's Pool. The feds had Biker Bobbie in the crosshairs.
那名女性志愿者——那个被死亡威胁单独列出来的——那个把两名潜水员的视频发送给国家海洋渔业局的人——她被视为联邦证人。威胁联邦证人是联邦犯罪，所以FBI介入了。他们通过IP地址追踪到距离儿童泳池五个街区外的一家公共图书馆。联邦当局锁定了Biker Bobbie。
Now, what he did was he went to the public library and he had an account called-- it was [email protected] . And then he would log in to his personal account two seconds later. So that's how they caught him.
他做的是去公共图书馆，他有一个账号叫……[email protected]。然后他会在两秒后登录他的个人账号。他们就是这样抓到他的。
And when they confronted the author of the emails, it turned out he was not an actual biker, nor was he a Bobbie. He was a scientist.
当他们质问邮件作者时，发现他根本不是什么骑手，也不是什么Bobbie。他是一名科学家。
Yeah, I sent them. Yeah. I sent them out of anger.
是的，是我发的。是的。我是因为愤怒才发的。
It was our marine science guy, Kent Trego.
那就是我们的海洋科学派，肯特·特雷戈。
I regretted it. I regretted it after I did it. It just built up on me. And it was just one of those moments. But it was all words. There was never any-- never any intentions to hurt anybody.
我很后悔。我做完之后就后悔了。这只是在我身上累积起来的。那只是那一刻的一时冲动。但那只是些话而已。从来没有……从来没有伤害任何人的意图。
Kent remembers being at the Children's Pool on that day when the seal activist filmed the license plate of his two scuba diver pals. But he says he doesn't remember much else. He couldn't tell me any details from that day. Says he can't remember what he wrote in the emails. Even talking about it now-- it makes him squirm pretty good.
肯特记得那天他在儿童泳池，当时海豹激进分子拍摄了他那两名水肺潜水员朋友的车牌。但他说是他不记得其他事情了。他无法告诉我那天细节。说他不记得他在邮件里写了什么。即使现在谈起，这也会让他感到相当不安。
It wasn't meant to be a real threat or anything like that.
它并不是真的威胁或类似的事情。
Obviously, the person receiving it on the other side would take it a little differently, I guess. The plan, I'm guessing, was just to scare them back-- to brush them back.
显然，接收它的人会有不同的解读，我想。计划大概只是为了吓退他们，为了让他们撤回去。
But I didn't even-- I didn't even-- as far as I recall, the content wasn't even meant to scare anybody. It was just more of a-- just a reaction.
但我甚至没……甚至没……据我回忆，内容甚至不是为了吓唬谁。这更像是一种……只是一种反应。
You were pretty direct about some stuff.
你对某些事情相当直白。
Yeah, like I said, I don't remember what I said. But I shouldn't have said it. But no, I didn't have any intention of hurting anybody. It's not a common sense reaction.
是的，就像我说的那样，我不记得我说了什么。但我确实不应该说那些话。但没有，我没有任何伤害任何人的意图。这不是一种常识性的反应。
Things started to come into sharper focus after he was arrested by federal agents as he walked back to his car from the beach. Kent pled guilty to the charge of threatening a federal witness. He served four and a half months in federal prison and then another six months of house arrest. He was banned from using a computer for a couple of years and ordered to stay away from the Children's Pool.
在他从海滩回车的路上被联邦特工逮捕后，事情开始变得清晰起来。肯特对威胁联邦证人的指控认罪。他在联邦监狱服刑了四个月，随后又接受了六个月的居家监禁。他被禁止使用电脑几年，并被要求远离儿童泳池。
He took full responsibility for his actions. He apologized to the victim in court. He sent a letter of apology to the Animal Protection and Rescue League.
他为自己的行为承担了全部责任。他在法庭上向受害者道歉。他向动物保护与救援联盟寄去了一封道歉信。
I tried to push Kent for details-- for an explanation-- just why he did it. Was there a chain of events? A final straw? He couldn't really give me a clear reason.
我试图向肯特索要细节——一个解释——为什么他会这样做。是因为一连串事件吗？最后一根稻草吗？他真的没能给我一个明确的原因。
I guess, just wanted-- felt like you wanted to get even for some reason or whatever, or do something.
我想，大概就是……感觉你想因为某种原因寻求报复，或者做点什么。
I do know because I'm a human being. And really, who hasn't taken things a step or two further than maybe they should have? Like one time-- I've got this neighbor. He's a half block away from me. And on hot summer days, he'd blast his music really loud and it was always Alice in Chains, a band that I used to love before this.
我知道，因为我也是人类。真的，谁没有把事情做得比可能应该做的更过分一步或两步呢？就像有一次……我有个邻居。他离我半个街区远。在炎热的夏日，他会把音乐开得震天响，而且总是放Alice in Chains，我曾经很喜欢的一支乐队。
Anyway, my daughter Addie-- she was less than two-- 18 months. And she was a light sleeper. And it was already hard to get her down for naps. And then Alice in Chains would start rattling the neighborhood.
总之，我女儿阿迪——她还不到两岁——18个月大。她睡眠很浅。让她午睡已经够难的了。然后Alice in Chains就开始震动整个社区。
Addie starts crying, so I run to the neighbor's house and pound on the door. The guy doesn't answer so I call the cops. They show up and shut the neighbor down.
阿迪开始哭，所以我跑到邻居家敲门。那家伙不开门，我就报警。他们到了并让邻居停下来。
The next day, same thing. It happened, like, six more times. Eventually, the cops stopped responding and nobody else seemed to care. And the sound blasting out of the neighbor's stereo made something come loose inside me.
第二天，同样的事情又发生了。发生了大概六次。最终，警察不再响应，其他人似乎也不在乎。邻居音响里传出的声音让我内心深处有什么东西松动了。
I went to my bedroom and unlocked my gun case and I loaded a revolver. And I walked out in my backyard to the corner closest to the music and bam, bam, bam, bam. I fired four shots into the dirt.
我走到卧室，打开枪盒，给左轮手枪装上子弹。我走到后院最靠近音乐的角落，砰，砰，砰，砰。我对着泥土开了四枪。
My wife is screaming at me and it hits me all at once. I'm the guy who's terrorizing the neighborhood. My wife didn't speak to me for a week.
我妻子冲我大喊，我一下子清醒了。我成了那个恐吓社区的人。我妻子一周没跟我说话。
So I get it. Everybody has their limits. All of us.
所以我明白了。每个人都有底线。我们所有人。
Tell me about the stun gun.
跟我讲讲那个电击枪。
Well, that. Yeah. I'm happy to talk about that. I'm so sick of talking about it that I didn't bring it up. But you guys have turned over every rock in this.
好吧，那个。是的。我很乐意谈论那个。我谈得太恶心了，以至于我不想提。但你们已经把这里的一切都翻了个底朝天。
Yep. Even our animal-protecting, confrontation-avoiding attorney, Brian Pease. One of his fellow seal activists-- a woman-- had been raking seaweed one day at the Children's Pool, trying to create a mound or a barrier so she could tell visitors to stay behind it. And there was this 55-year-old shared use guy who was kicking away the seaweed line and just being a jerk.
是的。甚至包括我们的动物保护、避免冲突的律师，布莱恩·皮斯。他的一位海豹激进分子同事——一位女性——有一天在儿童泳池耙海藻，试图制造一个土堆或屏障，好让游客待在它后面。有个55岁的共享利用派家伙在踢开海藻线，纯粹是在找茬。
She called me and told me that he's drunk. He's harassing the seals. He's harassing her. Can you do something? So I said, all right, I'm going to come down there. And I brought this thing for protection.
她打电话给我说他喝醉了。他在骚扰海豹。他在骚扰她。你能做点什么吗？所以我说，好吧，我要去那边。我带了这个东西以防万一。
This thing, being the stun gun. Now, Brian went out of his way to explain that it wasn't technically a stun gun. This point was really important to him.
这个东西，是电击枪。现在，布莱恩竭力解释说这在技术上不是电击枪。这一点对他来说非常重要。
Says he had an expert witness declare it not a stun gun. But it says stun gun on the package and that's how the newspapers reported it. In any case, when he got down to the beach, the seaweed kicker confronted him.
说他有一位专家证人宣布它不是电击枪。但包装上写着电击枪，报纸也是这么报道的。总之，他到了海滩时，那个踢海藻的人和他对质。
And then I'm standing near where this kelp line is. And he's just going back and forth from the kelp and then dumping it in the water. And then he comes back, picks up another two handfuls full of kelp and he goes, oh, you want some of this? And he just slings it right in my face-- just whips it right at me.
我站在海带线附近。他在海带线来回走动，然后把它扔进水里。然后他回来，抓起另外两把海带说，哦，你想要点这个吗？然后他直接把它甩在我脸上——直接朝我扔过来。
That's when I pulled out the device, which I now know is not a stun gun, but it was a deterrent device. And I did try to-- I pushed him back with it. He admitted in the police report that he was not shocked through his thick sweatshirt.
就在那时我拿出了设备，我现在知道那不是电击枪，但它是一种威慑设备。我确实试着……我用它把他推开。他在警察报告中承认他并没有因为厚厚的运动衫而受到电击。
You brought this device down there? You had a reason and then you felt emboldened enough to use it, right?
你带了这个设备去那里？你有一个理由，然后你觉得足够有底气使用它，对吧？
From my perspective, I was enforcing the law. He's harassing seals. He's harassing people. And he attacked me and I was using reasonable force to defend myself.
从我的角度来看，我是在执行法律。他在骚扰海豹。他在骚扰人。他袭击了我，我是在使用合理的武力保护自己。
Anyway, the two men grappled and went to the ground.
总之，两人扭打在一起倒在地上。
Yeah. I think I pinned him down. I was saying, call the police.
是的。我想我把他压在下面了。我一直在说，报警。
He was drunk. He was agitated. He was just being belligerent.
他喝醉了。他很激动。他只是在好战。
But the stun-- yeah. I guess, when you ask what would I have done over again, I probably would have just pinned him down again. But the stun gun would not have been-- I call it a stun gun, but it's really not. This zapping device would not have been involved.
但电击……是的。我想，当你问我会重新做什么时，我可能只会再次把他压住。但电击枪就不会被……我叫它电击枪，但它真的不是。这个电击设备就不会被卷入其中。
Bryan was the one who was arrested. He pled no contest to assault with a stun gun. Bryan's a smart guy and super thoughtful. But I think he got caught up in his herd's mentality and people here forgot that there are more options than just fight or flight.
布莱恩是被逮捕的人。他承认了使用电击枪袭击的指控。布莱恩很聪明，非常体贴。但我认为他陷入了这种群体心态，这里的人忘了选择不止是战斗或逃跑。
They went right to their reptilian brain and their prefrontal cortex got shut off there. Is that you're saying?
他们直接进入了爬行动物大脑模式，前额叶皮层在那儿关闭了？你是这个意思吗？
Yeah. It feels that way. And for me, personally, somebody gets in my face, I don't think about the legal parts of it or whatever. I react from the animal part of me, right?
是的。感觉就是这样。对我个人来说，有人凑到我面前，我不会考虑其中的法律部分或其他什么。我从我的动物本能出发，对吧？
That's what I did. And that's why I didn't want to go there anymore. It's almost like asking for trouble. Why do it? Why go there?
我就是这么做的。这就是我为什么不想再去那儿的原因。简直就像是在自找麻烦。为什么要这样做？为什么要再去？
The appropriate thing would be just to walk away from it and just be gone.
合适的做法是直接走开，然后离开。
This is Kent again. And on this point, both men agree.
这是肯特，又是肯特。在这一点上，两人都同意。
And that's what I should have done if I had been smart about it. I think that's what people need to do in conflicting situations-- walk away from them. I'll never be involved in anything like this again. Period.
那才是我如果聪明的话应该做的。我认为人们在冲突的情况下需要做的是——走开。我再也不会参与任何这样的事情了。句号。
In the summer of 2014, the California Coastal Commission voted to completely close the beach at Children's Pool to humans during pupping season, from December 15 to May 15. Bryan and Kent both support this decision. Anybody who wants to see the seals can still watch them from the sidewalk and the seawall.
2014年夏天，加州海岸委员会投票决定在产仔季节，即12月15日至5月15日，完全禁止人类进入儿童泳池海滩。布莱恩和肯特都支持这一决定。任何想看海豹的人仍然可以从人行道和防波堤上观看。
And it works. People aren't screaming at each other. Seals aren't being flushed from the beach.
而且它有效。人们不再互相尖叫。海豹不再被从海滩上赶走。
During the rest of the year, there's a permanent guideline rope down on the sand to provide a buffer between humans and harbor seals. It's not perfect, but it's a pretty good compromise. Some of the seal activists are still patrolling the beach during the seven months when it's partially opened to the public. And some of the shared use people are mounting a legal campaign to have the Coastal Commission decision overturned. But mostly, it's just nice now.
在这一年的其余时间里，沙滩上有一根永久性的引导绳，在人类和港海豹之间提供缓冲。它并不完美，但这是一个相当好的妥协。一些海豹激进分子在向公众部分开放的七个月里仍然在海滩上巡逻。一些共享利用派的人正在开展法律行动，要求撤销海岸委员会的决定。但最重要的是，现在这里感觉不错。
Daddy, look, I see one! Right there! Right there.
爸爸，看，我看到一只！就在那儿！就在那儿。
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
The thing that you don't hear in all those YouTube videos is the sound of the place without the hate, when people are not screaming. When the sun is shining and the seals are sprawled out across the white sand.
你在那些YouTube视频中听不到的是，当没有仇恨、人们不再尖叫时，那个地方的声音。当阳光普照，海豹横卧在白沙滩上时。
Look, he's rolling onto his stomach.
看，它正在翻身趴在肚皮上。
Sometimes you see a mother nursing her pups. It feels like you're being let in on a secret, like this is how the world is without us. We, as a species, are aggressive.
有时你会看到母亲在哺育幼崽。这感觉就像你被允许分享一个秘密，就像这就是没有我们时世界本来的样子。作为一个物种，我们是有侵略性的。
We're predatory, territorial. We're pretty selfish. And here at the Children's Pool, we've got the place surrounded. The seals keep coming back. Clearly, they like it here.
我们是掠食性的，领地意识强。我们很自私。在这里的儿童泳池，我们把这个地方包围了。海豹继续回来。显然，它们喜欢这里。
Here comes another one up there on that little island.
那边的那个小岛上又上来了一只。
And even though I don't have any evidence or scientific data to prove it, I still think that the seals totally dig us, despite our natures.
尽管我没有任何证据或科学数据来证明这一点，但我依然认为海豹完全喜欢我们，尽管我们的本性如此。
James Spring in San Diego. Since we first aired this story a year ago, a group of the shared use advocates sued the city of San Diego to get the beach opened up again year round to humans. A judge ruled in their favor last May. The city appealed that decision and was granted the right to close the beach this winter while the court case plays out.
詹姆斯·斯普林在圣地亚哥。自从我们一年前首次播出这个故事以来，一群共享利用拥护者起诉圣地亚哥市，要求海滩全年向人类开放。法官去年五月作出了有利于他们的裁决。市政府对该决定提出了上诉，并被准许在诉讼期间在今年冬天关闭海滩。
Coming up, the most successful animal outlaw the range country out west every knew. And by that, I mean the animal itself was seen as a criminal. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，西部草原上曾经知道的最成功的动物亡命之徒。我的意思是，动物本身被视为罪犯。一分钟后，从芝加哥公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "When the Beasts Come Marching In." We have stories of what happens when animals intrude on the world that we humans have constructed for ourselves. We've arrived at Act Two of our program.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，“当猛兽来袭”。我们有关于当动物闯入我们人类为自己建造的世界时会发生什么的故事。我们已经进入节目的第二幕。
Act Two, "Hungry Like a US Department of Agriculture Contract Employee." OK. Back in Act One of our show, we heard about modern people trying to accommodate the wild animals that just show up in their midst. But of course, back in the day, generally, a wild animal showed up, we would just kill it. Take, for example, this press release that the federal government put out nearly 100 years ago.
第二幕，“像美国农业部合同员工一样饥饿”。好的。在节目的第一幕，我们听到了现代人试图适应出现在他们中间的野生动物。但当然，在过去，通常当野生动物出现时，我们只会杀死它。以联邦政府近100年前发布的一份新闻稿为例。
"US department of Agriculture press release. Monday, January 17, 1921. The Custer Wolf is dead.
“美国农业部新闻稿。1921年1月17日，星期一。卡斯特狼死了。
He was the master criminal of the animal world. For nine years, this wolf had lived as an outlaw. The cruelest, the most sagacious, the most successful animal outlaw that the range country had ever known. His cruelty was surpassed only by his cunning. Here tonight, tomorrow night he'd devastated a range half a hundred miles away."
它是动物界的犯罪大师。九年来，这只狼一直作为亡命之徒生活。这是草原上所知的最残忍、最睿智、最成功的动物亡命之徒。它的残忍仅次于它的狡猾。今晚在这里，明晚它就在五十英里外的草原上肆虐。”
Yes, this is an actual press release from the federal government about the government hiring a guy to kill a wolf. Actor Michael Chernus read it for us. And OK, some context. Wolves used to be common in the mountains out west.
是的，这是一份来自联邦政府关于政府雇人杀狼的真实新闻稿。演员迈克尔·切纳斯为我们朗读了它。好的，提供一些背景。狼曾经在西部的山脉中很常见。
But when settlers arrived, we killed off the animals that wolves used to feed on-- bison, elk, deer. And so the wolves turned to livestock-- our livestock-- for food. We were not into that at all.
但当定居者到达后，我们杀死了狼曾经赖以生存的动物——野牛、麋鹿、鹿。所以狼转向了牲畜——我们的牲畜——来寻找食物。我们一点也不喜欢那样。
So ranchers and the federal government set out to exterminate the wolves. Between 1883 and 1930, more than 80,000 wolves were killed for bounties in Montana alone. And the governor wanted everybody to know what a good job they were doing for the taxpayers. And so they put out press releases that include facts, but do not seem constrained by facts. Though it does seem true that this wolf was really good at being a wolf.
所以牧场主和联邦政府着手灭绝狼。在1883年至1930年间，仅在蒙大拿州，就有超过8万只狼因悬赏而被杀。州长希望每个人都知道他们为纳税人做了多么好的工作。所以他们发布了新闻稿，其中包括事实，但似乎并不受事实限制。虽然这只狼确实非常擅长做狼，这似乎是真的。
"He loped through every kind of danger and spurned them all. He sniffed at the subtlest poison and passed it by. When he killed for food, he took only the choicest animals.
“它跳跃着穿过各种危险，并对它们不屑一顾。它嗅出最细微的毒药并绕道而行。当它捕食时，它只选择最上等的动物。
But sometimes, he killed in atrocious ways for the mere sake of killing. Often he wounded cattle, breaking their legs, biting off their tails, mutilating them in unspeakable ways. And there was no man throughout that region who did not feel a shiver run down between his shoulder blades when, alone or in the dark, he thought of this gray devil of the desert.
但有时，它仅仅为了杀戮而以残暴的方式杀害动物。它经常伤害牛，折断它们的腿，咬掉它们的尾巴，以无法形容的方式残害它们。在该地区，没有一个人在独自一人或在黑暗中想到这只沙漠灰魔鬼时，脊背不感到寒意。
Four years ago, his mate was killed. He never took another. And many people supposed that he devoted himself to revenge for her death.
四年前，它的配偶被杀了。它再也没有找过别的配偶。许多人认为它致力于为她的死复仇。
Later on, he attached to himself two coyotes-- not his equals, but his servants. He never permitted them to come near him and they could feed from his kills only after he himself had finished. They traveled far out on his flanks, giving him warning of ambush or approaching danger, and adding to the atmosphere of mystery that surrounded him."
后来，它给自己招募了两只土狼——不是它的同类，而是它的仆人。它从不允许它们靠近自己，只有在它自己吃完后，它们才能吃它杀死的猎物。它们在它的侧翼远行，给它提供伏击或即将到来的危险预警，并增加了围绕着它的神秘氛围。”
OK. I'm just going to jump in here again. This is the federal government sending this out as a press release. And it says they took nine years to capture this wolf.
好的。我又要插话了。这是联邦政府作为新闻稿发出的。它说他们花了九年时间才抓住这只狼。
The wolf operated around Custer, South Dakota. And the fact that they gave him a name-- "The Custer Wolf"-- that was something they did with a lot of notorious wolves back then. So how did it take nine years?
狼在南达科他州的卡斯特周围活动。他们给它起了一个名字——“卡斯特狼”——那是当时他们对许多臭名昭著的狼所做的事情。那为什么花了九年？
Well, the press release explains the bounty started at $100. And trappers tried, sportsmen tried. They used poison, they used dogs. Nobody could kill this wolf. They raised the bounty higher and higher, year after year, till it was $500.
好吧，新闻稿解释说悬赏从100美元开始。捕兽者试过，运动员试过。他们用过毒药，用过狗。没有人能杀死这只狼。他们一年又一年地提高赏金，直到500美元。
And eight years in, in March of 1920, USDA's Bureau of Biological Survey went to a hunter named HP Williams, who I'm picturing-- actually, I'm picturing the shark hunter in the movie Jaws, though I have no facts at all to support that.
第八年，1920年3月，美国农业部生物调查局找到了一个名叫惠普·威廉姆斯的猎人，我在脑海中勾勒他的形象——其实，我勾勒的是电影《大白鲨》里的鲨鱼猎人，虽然我没有任何事实依据支持这一点。
The government goes to him with instructions to stay with the wolf until the wolf is killed no matter how much time it takes. Williams went.
政府带着指令去找他，让他留在狼身边，直到狼被杀死，无论花多少时间。威廉姆斯去了。
And since there is involved in this story the reputation of two geniuses, the criminal genius of the wolf and the protective genius of Williams, it may be just as well to let the account proceed in the language of the animal inspector who reported the facts to the biological survey. Like most outdoor men, he did not want to talk in heroics. Here is the story.
而且由于这个故事涉及两位天才的名声，狼的犯罪天才和威廉姆斯的保护天才，最好让报道以向生物调查局报告事实的动物检查员的语言进行。像大多数户外工作者一样，他不想用英雄主义的话语来谈论。这是故事。
Quote, "When Williams first went into the country where the wolf ranged, he tried to find fresh tracks, but without success. He asked some of the men who had lost stock just where the wolf made his headquarters in their section. Contrary to their advice, Williams went into the hills west of Pringle and found that the wolf was staying around some old dens in Pilger mountains.
引述，“当威廉姆斯第一次进入狼活动的地区时，他试图寻找新鲜的足迹，但没有成功。他问了一些失去家畜的人，狼在他们那一部分的总部设在哪里。与他们的建议相反，威廉姆斯进入了普林格以西的山区，发现狼正呆在皮尔格山的一些旧巢穴周围。
Williams scented up the soles of his shoes and started stringing out his traps. The wolf got on his trail that night and showed signs of great excitement at what he thought to be the presence of a possible mate in his neighborhood.
威廉姆斯在鞋底涂上香味，开始布下陷阱。狼那天晚上顺着他的踪迹走，对自己认为附近可能存在配偶的表现出极大的兴奋。
On April 1, Williams had his first glimpse of the wolf. He wasn't able to get a shot at him. The coyotes were acting as bodyguards, traveling from 100 to 200 yards on the flanks of their mother. They would warn him of danger by taking flight.
4月1日，威廉姆斯第一次瞥见了这只狼。他没能有机会向它开枪。土狼充当了保镖，在母亲的侧翼旅行100到200码。它们会通过逃跑来警告它危险。
For a while, Williams did not shoot the coyotes, hoping that he would get a chance at the wolf without having to give him warning by the shots that would be necessary to dispatch his bodyguard. Finally, realizing there was no chance of getting at the wolf unless the coyotes were killed, Williams shot them hoping that he, then, had a clear field. In this, he was greatly mistaken.
有一段时间，威廉姆斯没有射杀土狼，希望能在不发出警告的情况下获得射击狼的机会，因为射杀保镖是必须发出的枪声。最后，意识到除非土狼被杀死，否则没有机会接近狼，威廉姆斯射杀了它们，希望这样自己就有了清晰的射击场地。在这点上，他大错特错了。
The wolf played hide and seek with him. After making a kill, he would go on some distance, back trail for a few rounds to a point where he could keep undercover and watch the hunter on his trail. Though this is a common habit of a bear, I have never before known a wolf to do it."
狼和他玩起了躲猫猫。在捕食后，它会走一段距离，倒退几圈到一点，在那里它可以保持隐蔽并监视踪迹上的猎人。虽然这是熊的常见习惯，但我以前从未听说过狼会这样做。”
The press release continues with more detail about the hunt. My favorite scene in this whole thing is in August. The Custer Wolf vanishes for over a month.
新闻稿继续提供了关于狩猎的更多细节。我在这整件事中最喜欢的场景是在8月。卡斯特狼消失了一个多月。
And then Williams trails him to a canyon and is right about to shoot him when two guys on horseback ride in at, quote "breakneck speed," to inform Williams about another animal that was killed by the wolf. And Williams motions for them to go away, but they don't understand what he means. And so basically, they make so much noise, they scare away the wolf and Williams loses the wolf again. A month later, the wolf gets his foot caught in a trap, but not completely, and he pulls it out. This happens again in October.
然后威廉姆斯追踪它到一个峡谷，正要射杀它时，两个骑马的家伙以“飞快的速度”骑了进来，通知威廉姆斯关于狼杀死的另一只动物。威廉姆斯示意他们走开，但他们不明白他的意思。所以基本上，他们制造了太大的噪音，吓跑了狼，威廉姆斯又失去了狼的踪迹。一个月后，狼的脚被陷阱卡住，但没有完全卡住，它把它拔了出来。这在10月又发生了一次。
Williams finally got the wolf on October 11. Here is his own account of it. Quote, "He stepped into a trap in the morning and it got a good grip on him. He broke the swivel of the trap and ran on with it on his front foot. I trailed him three miles and got a shot at him and got him. He's been so lucky that I expected the gun would fail to shoot, but it worked OK."
威廉姆斯终于在10月11日抓到了狼。这是他自己的叙述。引述，“它早上踩进了陷阱，陷阱抓住了它。它弄断了陷阱的转环，前脚带着它跑了。我追踪了它三英里，有机会开了一枪并抓住了它。它一直很幸运，以至于我预计枪会无法开火，但它工作得很好。”
The Custer Wolf was smaller than the average male wolf. It weighed 98 pounds. It measured just six feet, tip to tip. He was an old wolf, with fur that was almost white. His teeth, the press release notes, would have been good for 15 years longer.
卡斯特狼比普通雄狼小。它重98磅。它从头到尾只有六英尺长。它是一只老狼，毛发几乎是白色的。新闻稿指出，它的牙齿本来还可以再用15年。
Thanks to Laurel Braitman, who told us about this press release. It's kind of a famous one among wolf people, apparently. She's writing a book about animal outlaws.
感谢劳雷尔·布雷特曼告诉我们关于这份新闻稿的事。显然，它在狼圈中相当有名。她正在写一本关于动物亡命之徒的书。
[WOLF HOWLING]
[狼嚎声]
Act Three, "Weeknight at Bernie's." So after all these stories of conflict between humans and animals, let us close out our show today in a city where people actually take pride-- many of them do, anyway-- in being able to co-exist side by side with wild animals. It is actual city policy to try to co-exist. That utopian place-- Anchorage, Alaska, a town of 300,000 that bear and moose wander through. There are beluga whales in the water on the edge of town.
第三幕，“伯尼的周日之夜”。所以，在所有这些人类与动物冲突的故事之后，让我们以一个城市作为我们节目的结尾，在那里人们实际上为能与野生动物共存而感到自豪——当然，许多人是这样。尝试共存是实际的城市政策。那个乌托邦式的地方——阿拉斯加州安克雷奇，一个有30万人口的城镇，熊和驼鹿在里面徘徊。城边水里有白鲸。
But most of the animals-- they come and go. And nobody knows them well. Nobody remembers them when they're gone. John Mooallem has the story of one animal that stood out-- that became a resident of the city in a way that few non-humans ever do.
但大多数动物——它们来来去去。没有人很好地了解它们。当它们离开时，没有人记得它们。约翰·穆艾勒姆有一个故事，关于一只出众的动物——它以极少数非人类能够做到的方式成为了这个城市的居民。
Stop me if you've heard this one. A moose walks into a bar--
如果听过这个，请打断我。一只驼鹿走进一家酒吧……
--in the courtyard of Bernie's bungalow lounge. It's totally fenced off with just one or two little gates in it. And I guess they weren't used to seeing moose right there.
……在伯尼平房休息室的庭院里。它被完全围起来，只有一两个小门。我猜他们不习惯在那里看到驼鹿。
That's Rick Sinnott, and that's the call he got late one night about a moose hanging out at a bar in downtown Anchorage-- a martini lounge, actually. The moose was humongous. It wasn't supposed to be at a martini lounge because it was a moose.
那是里克·辛诺特，这就是他在深夜收到的电话，关于一只驼鹿在安克雷奇市中心的一家酒吧闲逛——实际上是一家马提尼酒廊。这只驼鹿庞大无比。它不应该在马提尼酒廊，因为它是只驼鹿。
Rick was the guy you'd call for problems like that. For 30 years, his official job description was Wildlife Biologist for the State Fish and Game Department. But really, he saw himself as a referee. All around Anchorage, Rick says, you've got this endless scrimmage playing out between people and wild animals all trying to live in the same space.
里克就是处理那种问题的人。30年来，他的官方职位描述是州鱼类和狩猎部的野生动物生物学家。但实际上，他把自己视为裁判。在安克雷奇各地，里克说，你有这种在人和野生动物之间上演的无休止的争夺，都在试图生活在同一个空间里。
It was up to Rick to manage that coexistence. And he'd get dozens of calls a day-- 800-pound black bears on people's decks, wolves eating dogs. Years ago, there was an infamous spate of attacks by a cantankerous great horned owl who kept dive bombing skiers with its steak knife talons. But lots of calls didn't really seem like problems Rick needed to rush out and solve.
管理这种共存取决于里克。他每天接到几十个电话——人们露台上800磅重的黑熊，狼吃狗。几年前，有一连串臭名昭著的攻击事件，来自一只脾气暴躁的大角鸮，它用牛排刀一样的爪子不断俯冲轰炸滑雪者。但很多电话并不真正看起来像是里克需要冲过去解决的问题。
Someone will say, there's a-- I need to get to work and there's a moose between me and my car and I can't go out the front door. I wouldn't go out for that unless someone was in a wheelchair or something, where they really couldn't go out the back door.
有人会说，有一只……我需要去工作，车和我不之间有一只驼鹿，我无法走出前门。如果有人坐在轮椅上或其他什么的，如果他们确实无法从后门出去，我不会为此出门。
What is your advice?
你的建议是什么？
My advice would be, call your boss and tell him you're going to be a few minutes late.
我的建议是，给老板打电话说你要晚几分钟。
Still, a moose at a bar is a higher order of moose problem. The animal could flip out.
尽管如此，酒吧里有一只驼鹿是更高级别的驼鹿问题。动物可能会发狂。
Every moose has sort of a bubble around him, conceptually, where they feel threatened. They're all potentially dangerous and they don't use their antlers, really, when they attack you. They use their hooves in front and they're very large and very heavy and very sharp. And they'll knock you down and do a little dance on you.
每只驼鹿周围都有一个概念上的气泡，在那里它们感到受到威胁。它们都有潜在的危险，而且攻击你时并不真正使用鹿角。它们使用前面的蹄子，它们非常大、非常重、非常锋利。它们会把你撞倒并在你身上跳个舞。
So Rick got in his truck and headed over to Bernie's. The place isn't the least bit secluded. It's right in the heart of downtown Anchorage, across from the Nordstrom's.
所以里克上了他的卡车，开往伯尼那边。那个地方一点也不偏僻。它就在安克雷奇市中心的心脏地带，对面是诺德斯特龙百货。
And yet, when Rick showed up, the moose was just standing there in the courtyard, stock still, unfazed, even with a crowd of people around it. It was strange. This moose seemed to require zero personal moose space.
然而，当里克出现时，驼鹿只是静静地站在庭院里，一动不动，毫不在意，即使周围挤满了人。这很奇怪。这只驼鹿似乎根本不需要个人驼鹿空间。
He was a big moose. He was probably 1,400 pounds-- something like that. And his antlers were-- I don't know-- at least three feet across from tip to tip, maybe four feet.
它是一只大驼鹿。它可能有1400磅——大概是那样。它的鹿角从尖到尖至少有三英尺宽，也许四英尺。
His knees are locked and he's got this 1,000-yard stare. And the only way you can really tell he's alive is you see these great big gouts of steam coming out of his nostrils every time he breathes out. He's just totally out of it, just standing there drunk, basically.
它的膝盖锁死了，眼神呆滞。你真正能看出它还活着的唯一方法是看到它每次呼气时从鼻孔喷出的巨大蒸汽。它完全醉了，基本上就站在那儿。
Yeah. The moose was hammered.
是的。驼鹿喝醉了。
There was one or two very large crabapple trees in the courtyard. And the crab apples-- most of them had fallen off the trees and they were littering the courtyard-- hundreds of them. And they were soft and squishy-- definitely fermented.
庭院里有一两棵非常大的海棠树。海棠果——大部分已经从树上掉下来，撒在庭院里——几百个。它们又软又糊——绝对发酵了。
It's not uncommon, apparently. In winter, when there's only twigs to eat, a thick carpet of fallen fruit-- even rotting fruit-- is a pretty big caloric bonanza for a moose and they get plastered. A few years ago, reports surfaced from Sweden about a small gang of moose hoodlums drunk on crabapples, terrorizing homeowners. Outside the bar, Rick and a local newspaper reporter, named Julia O'Malley, sized up the situation.
这显然并不罕见。在冬天，当只有树枝可吃时，厚厚一层掉落的水果——甚至是腐烂的水果——对驼鹿来说是一场相当大的热量盛宴，它们会喝得烂醉。几年前，瑞典出现了关于一小群醉倒在海棠果上的驼鹿团伙恐吓房主的报道。酒吧外，里克和当地报纸记者朱莉娅·奥马利评估了情况。
And we walked around him and looked at him. And Julia asked me what I was going to do about it. And I said, you know?
我们绕着它走，看着它。朱莉娅问我打算怎么处理它。我说，你知道吗？
He's too large to fit in a taxi, so we're just going to leave him here until he works it out. He wasn't dangerous. He was drunk but not disorderly.
它太大坐不下出租车，所以我们就在这里留着它，直到它自己清醒过来。它没有危险。它醉了但并不扰乱治安。
Rick let the moose sleep it off. It was all he could do. Julia wrote up the incident in The Anchorage Daily News the next day-- a page one story. She gave the moose a nickname.
里克让驼鹿睡去酒气。这是他能做的全部。朱莉娅第二天在《安克雷奇日报》上写下了这件事——一篇头版故事。她给驼鹿取了个绰号。
Buzzwinkle. And we both giggled about that. Normally, I don't name animals. But when she named him Buzzwinkle and it was in the paper and everyone started calling him Buzzwinkle, then he became Buzzwinkle and I used the word, too. It's the world's stupidest name for a moose, but that was his name at that point.
Buzzwinkle。我们俩都为此咯咯笑。通常，我不给动物命名。但当她给它取名Buzzwinkle，并且上了报纸，每个人都开始叫它Buzzwinkle时，它就成了Buzzwinkle，我也用了这个词。这是世界上给驼鹿起的最蠢的名字，但在那个时候那是它的名字。
The drunk moose instantly became a local celebrity in Anchorage. It was a kind of municipal spirit animal. People started calling Rick all the time just to say they'd spotted Buzzwinkle clodding around Anchorage. Nothing Rick needed to do, they were just excited-- a star sighting.
这只醉驼鹿立即成为安克雷奇当地的明星。它是一种城市精神动物。人们开始一直给里克打电话，只是说他们看到Buzzwinkle在安克雷奇笨拙地走动。没什么里克需要做的，他们只是很兴奋——一次明星 sighting。
As it turns out, though, Rick was into this moose before he was famous. At the bar that night, he'd noticed an orange tag on Buzzwinkle's ear, the kind Rick attaches every time he handles a wild animal. When he got back to his office, he looked up the tag number.
然而事实证明，在它成名之前，里克就接触过这只驼鹿。在那晚的酒吧，他注意到Buzzwinkle耳朵上有一个橙色的标签，那是里克每次处理野生动物时都会附上的那种。回到办公室后，他查了标签号码。
I realized that we dealt with this exact same moose three years before. And that was a case where someone had hung a child's plastic hollow swing-- they'd hung it from a tree limb. And he'd been messing with it and gotten himself tangled up.
我意识到我们在三年前处理过同一只驼鹿。那是一起有人挂了一个儿童塑料空心秋千——他们把它挂在树枝上。它弄乱了它，把自己缠住了。
It had happened in the dead of night. Sounds a bit pathetic. Rick remembered how this swing kept lazily knocking into Buzzwinkle's head as the moose lurched and shrugged, trying to unsnag himself.
那发生在深夜。听起来有点可怜。里克记得当驼鹿踉跄并耸肩试图解开自己时，秋千是如何懒洋洋地撞击Buzzwinkle头部的。
Ultimately, Rick had to dart Buzzwinkle with a tranquilizer, then patiently unravel the whole tangle. It was like working through a pair of knotted up ear buds, but the problem was messier-- moosier. And Rick remembered bailing out Buzzwinkle one other time in the same neighborhood. He'd been hitting the crabapples that night, too.
最终，里克必须用镇静剂射击Buzzwinkle，然后耐心地解开整个纠结。这就像处理一双打结的耳机，但问题更混乱——更驼鹿化。里克还记得在同一个街区救过Buzzwinkle一次。那天晚上它也在吃海棠果。
Eating crabapples under someone's-- on someone's lawn. There were several crabapple trees. And he had a bunch of white lights dangling off of him. I don't know what-- 30 feet or more of white lights dangling off of his antlers.
在那个人……在某人的草坪上吃海棠果。有几棵海棠树。它身上挂着一串白色灯。我不知道是什么——30英尺或更多长的白色灯挂在它的鹿角上。
Turns out, this is another common moose problem. Rick saw it all the time. Moose wind up staggering around Anchorage with long trains of Christmas lights trailing behind them, or coaxial cable, or big yellow tether balls on ropes. Gradually, Rick pieced together that Buzzwinkle was probably the same big bullmoose he'd been seeing around town for years. And the reality was when he wasn't drunk, Buzzwinkle was actually a pretty canny animal. Street smart, Rick called him.
事实证明，这是另一个常见的驼鹿问题。里克经常看到这种情况。驼鹿最终拖着长长的圣诞灯串，或者是同轴电缆，或者是系在绳子上的大黄色系留球，在安克雷奇踉跄走动。渐渐地，里克拼凑出Buzzwinkle可能就是他多年来一直在城里看到的同一只大雄性驼鹿。现实是当它不醉时，Buzzwinkle实际上是一只相当聪明的动物。里克称它为“街头智慧”。
Buzzwinkle was a really laid back moose. He was super tolerant of people. That was one of the best things about him.
Buzzwinkle是一只非常随和的驼鹿。它对人超级包容。那是关于它最好的事情之一。
He was an urban moose. He was a-- he liked to spend time in the city. He'd come in for the weekend.
它是一只城市驼鹿。它……它喜欢在城市里花时间。它周末会来。
He was. I think-- some of our moose are in and out of the city. They'll come in the winter time and then they'll go back into the mountains. But this guy probably lived his whole life within a few mile radius of the downtown area, just walking around on the sidewalks and sometimes walking down the middle of the road.
它是。我想……我们的一些驼鹿是在城里进进出出。它们冬天会来，然后回到山里。但这只家伙可能一生都生活在市中心几英里的半径内，只是在人行道上走来走去，有时走在马路中间。
He was good, though, because if there wasn't much traffic, he would just assume the road was for him and he wouldn't walk on the sidewalk. But if there was a lot of traffic, he would use crosswalks. He would wait till the light-- at least I saw him do this once.
它很好，因为如果没有太多交通，它只会认为马路是它的，它不会在人行道上走。但如果有很多交通，它会使用人行横道。它会等到灯亮时……至少我见过它这样一次。
And I'm generalizing here a little bit. But he'd stand there on the sidewalk and watch the light. And when the cars stopped, he'd walk across the crosswalk.
而且我在这里稍微概括一下。但它会站在人行道上观察信号灯。当车停下来时，它会走过人行横道。
Picture that for a second. The moose would walk across the crosswalk with the light. It's a classic story. A guy from the sticks learning the ways of the big city, keeping his head down, trying to fit in.
想象一下那个画面。驼鹿随着信号灯走过人行横道。这是一个经典故事。一个来自乡下的家伙学习大城市的方式，保持低调，努力适应。
What kind of thing is a moose, anyway? Moose are the largest deer in the world. The big ones can stand six feet tall at the shoulder and weigh 3/4 of a ton. People like to call these animals distinguished and noble, but they make terrible moaning sounds, like phlegmy old men with gout.
驼鹿到底是什么样的东西？驼鹿是世界上最大的鹿。大的驼鹿肩高可以达到六英尺，重达四分之三吨。人们喜欢称这些动物为卓越和高贵的，但它们发出可怕的呻吟声，像有痛风的痰多老头。
I don't know why, but I just think moose are super weird. Lots of people do. Go look at one.
我不知道为什么，但我就是觉得驼鹿超级奇怪。很多人都这样觉得。去看看一只就知道了。
They have ridiculously huge heads with gawky antlers-- almost flat in places sometimes, like broad, buckled sheets of plywood. It's insane. It's amazing the animals don't fall over. And you know how big their brains are? The size of an orange.
它们有大得离谱的头和笨拙的鹿角——几乎有些地方是平的，像宽大、弯曲的胶合板片。这太疯狂了。令人惊叹的是动物竟然不会摔倒。你知道它们的大脑有多大吗？一个橘子那么大。
It just seems so odd that nature would make these hulking, vacant things and leave them standing around all over the place. And then, surprise, they can kill you. These dumb, agoraphobic vagrants with quick tempers and malfunctioning jackhammers for legs.
自然界造就这些庞大、空虚的东西，把它们留在到处徘徊，这似乎很奇怪。然后，惊喜，它们可以杀死你。这些愚蠢、有广场恐惧症的流浪者，脾气暴躁，腿部像打桩机一样故障。
In a way, it'd be safer and easier just to shoot them all. And to be totally clear, killing animals was part of Rick's job sometimes. But Anchorage is willing to put up with a lot more than most places before it draws that line.
在某种程度上，直接把它们全射杀会更安全、更简单。而且要完全清楚，杀动物有时是里克工作的一部分。但安克雷奇愿意忍受比大多数地方多得多的事情，才画出那条线。
One in 10 residents in Anchorage have smacked into a moose with their car. And still, a survey Rick did found that most people-- 87%-- felt these animals, quote, "Make life in Anchorage seem more interesting and special."
十分之一的安克雷奇居民曾开车撞过驼鹿。即便如此，里克做的一项调查发现，大多数人——87%——认为这些动物，引用，“让安克雷奇的生活看起来更有趣和特别。”
It's the same basic rules for animals as for people. As long as you don't hurt or threaten anyone, you can be as eccentric as you want, or even totally annoying, if that's your nature. You can stand on the sidewalk huffing and smelling gross and making upsetting noises.
对动物和对人的基本规则是一样的。只要你不伤害或威胁任何人，你可以随心所欲地古怪，或者如果你本性如此，甚至完全令人讨厌。你可以站在人行道上呼哧呼哧地喘气，闻起来很恶心，发出令人不安的声音。
You do you. Society will do its best to tolerate you. And sometimes even send out a caseworker in the middle of the night to help you if, say, you get your giant head stuck in a swing.
做你自己。社会将尽力容忍你。有时甚至会在深夜派出个案经理来帮助你，如果，比如，你的巨大脑袋卡在秋千上。
A couple of months after the night at the martini lounge, Rick started getting some calls from concerned residents that Buzzwinkle looked hurt. He was walking funny. So Rick went to check on the moose. He found him at a creek behind an industrial area in town.
在那晚马提尼酒廊后的几个月，里克开始接到一些关心居民的电话，说Buzzwinkle看起来受伤了。它走起路来很奇怪。所以里克去检查驼鹿。他在镇上一个工业区后面的一条小溪边找到了它。
And he had been injured somehow. And I initially thought it was-- a car had hit him in one of his rear legs. Because he had a big gash and a big lump there-- a little bit of blood. But it just looked like it was infected and he was gimping around. And so what we do then is we just watch and wait.
它以某种方式受伤了。我最初认为它是……车撞了它的一条后腿。因为那里有一个大伤口和一个大肿块——有一点血。但它看起来像是感染了，它在那儿一瘸一拐地走。所以我们当时能做的就是观察和等待。
Rick figured if Buzzwinkle could hang on till spring, when there'd be more plants to eat, he'd have a shot at recovering. For the rest of the winter, when people called in Buzzwinkle sightings, Rick always asked them, how does he look? How is he walking?
里克想如果Buzzwinkle能坚持到春天，那时会有更多的植物可吃，它就有机会恢复。在剩下的冬天里，当人们打电话报告Buzzwinkle的 sightings时，里克总是问他们，它看起来怎么样？它走得怎么样？
But then, someone reported a bull moose crumpled on the ground. Rick found the animal in a vacant lot behind a printing business.
但后来，有人报告一只雄性驼鹿蜷缩在地上。里克在一家印刷企业后面的空地上找到了那只动物。
I walked up and looked and I could see the orange tag in his ear. I looked. I checked the number. It was definitely Buzzwinkle. Well, you could actually still see the wound, which had sort of closed up. But it was still there on his back leg.
我走过去看了看，看到了它耳朵上的橙色标签。我看了看。我查了号码。它绝对是Buzzwinkle。好吧，你实际上仍然可以看到伤口，它某种程度上已经愈合了。但在它的后腿上依然存在。
He was lying on his side, up against this wooden fence. And he was so skinny. He was emaciated.
它侧躺着，靠在这个木栅栏上。它太瘦了。它骨瘦如柴。
At some point in the night, probably, he had just fallen over. And he couldn't get up. You could see his chest was moving and his eyes were blinking a little bit. But he couldn't even raise his head.
在深夜的某个时刻，大概，它就摔倒了。它站不起来了。你可以看到它的胸部在移动，眼睛在微微眨动。但它甚至无法抬起头。
How did it affect you to see him like that?
看着它那样对你有什么影响？
Well, it was sad. It was just-- it was the last, maybe, hours of his life-- certainly, the last day or two. So I walked back to the truck and loaded the shotgun.
好吧，这很悲伤。这只是……这是它生命中最后的几个小时——当然，最后的一天或两天。所以我走回卡车，装填了猎枪。
Rick wrote an essay about Buzzwinkle in The Anchorage Daily News, a kind of eulogy. I asked him to read his description of what happened next.
里克在《安克雷奇日报》上写了一篇关于Buzzwinkle的文章，一种悼词。我请他读了他对接下来发生事情的描述。
"TS Eliot could have been thinking of moose when he proclaimed April the cruelest month. With its reserves depleted, the larder empty, and nothing green in sight, it's not uncommon for a moose to succumb during the slow transition from winter to spring. I couldn't leave Buzzwinkle helpless, feebly tracing arcs in the dirt with his hooves to be worried by dogs or to lose his eyes to a raven. I shot him between the eyes.
“艾略特可能在宣告四月是最残酷的月份时就在想驼鹿。随着储备耗尽，储藏室空空如也，视线里没有绿色，驼鹿在从冬天到春天的缓慢过渡中死亡并不罕见。我不能让Buzzwinkle无助地躺着，虚弱地用蹄子在泥土中划出弧线，让狗去骚扰或让渡鸦啄掉它的眼睛。我射击了它的两眼之间。
I don't believe he saw me or felt the impact of the 12-gauge shotgun slug. After euthanizing the bull, I patted his neck and ran my index finger over his molars, worn to the gums. Buzzwinkle was a very old moose-- the oldest bull I'd ever seen."
我不相信它看到了我或感觉到了12号口径猎枪弹的冲击。在安乐死这头公牛后，我拍了拍它的脖子，用食指划过它的磨牙，牙齿已经磨损到了牙龈。Buzzwinkle是一只非常老的驼鹿——我见过的最老的公牛。”
He was at least 13, Rick says. That's how I first heard about Buzzwinkle, reading Rick's memorial to him in the paper. The emotion of it stuck with me-- the deep humanity of their relationship-- even though one of them was a moose. You can almost imagine it as a buddy film, though with a pretty twisted turn. Rick was the wingman who'd spent years looking out for his wilder, fun-loving, inebriated bro until all that hard living caught up with the guy and Rick had to shoot him in the face.
它至少有13岁了，里克说。这就是我第一次听说Buzzwinkle的方式，读到报纸上里克对它的纪念。其中的情感触动了我——他们之间关系的深刻人性——尽管其中一个是驼鹿。你几乎可以把它想象成一部好友电影，尽管带有一个相当扭曲的转折。里克是那个花多年照顾他那更狂野、爱玩、醉醺醺兄弟的侧翼，直到所有那些艰苦的生活追上了那家伙，里克不得不对他的脸射击。
Still, even that seemed like such a courageous act of mercy, of respect, performed with stoicism and a sense of duty. And when it was done, Rick wrote, he made special arrangements to use the moose's meat in a conservation research project. Buzzwinkle would be bait for trapping wolverines.
尽管如此，即使那似乎也是一种如此勇敢的仁慈行为，尊重，带着冷静和责任感。当它做完后，里克写道，他做了特别安排，将驼鹿的肉用于一个保护研究项目。Buzzwinkle将成为诱捕狼獾的诱饵。
I thought about that image a lot. I love the idea. Because in my mind, wolverines were the opposite of the caricature Buzzwinkle had become. He was goofy and urban and out getting tipsy, closing down the bar, whereas wolverines are nasty and elusive and relentlessly wild. Carving up Buzzwinkle for those animals seemed like a way to restore his wildness, to release his energy from our crummy world and feed it back into his. And anyway, the only other option would have been to haul Buzzwinkle to a landfill and that didn't sit right with Rick.
我思考了那个画面很多次。我喜欢这个主意。因为在我心中，狼獾是Buzzwinkle已成为的讽刺的对立面。它是笨拙的、城市的、出去喝得微醺的，在酒吧打烊，而狼獾是令人讨厌的、难以捉摸的、无情地狂野。为那些动物切割Buzzwinkle似乎是一种恢复它野性的方式，从我们这烂世界释放它的能量，并把它反馈给它的世界。总之，唯一的其他选择就是把Buzzwinkle拖到垃圾填埋场，那对里克来说感觉不对。
I always hated to do that. I did that one time early in my career. I took a dead moose to the landfill. And they charged me for it. I'm like, wait a minute.
我一直讨厌那样做。我职业生涯早期做过一次。我带了一只死驼鹿去垃圾填埋场。他们向我收费。我想，等等。
Wait. So your objection to taking a moose to a landfill was financial?
等等。所以你反对带驼鹿去垃圾填埋场的理由是经济上的？
Well, yeah. Time and money, sure.
好吧，是的。时间和金钱，当然。
I think I was just hoping for you having some kind of poetic, philosophic conviction about the circle of life and that a moose should not be buried in a landfill when it could be redistributed into the natural cycle.
我原以为你对生命循环有某种诗意的、哲学的信念，驼鹿在可以重新分配到自然循环中时不应该被埋在垃圾填埋场。
Oh, I can get all poetic on you if you want me to. But no, it was practical. It would be a two-hour round trip. And I'd pull up at the little kiosk and they would say, $50 to drop the moose off.
哦，如果你想的话我可以对你变得很诗意。但没，那是实用的。那将是一次两小时的往返。我会停在小亭子前，他们会说，50美元把驼鹿卸下来。
I kept pressing him, but he said it was a mistake to over romanticize this one moose just because it had a funny name. There were so many mooses Rick had known. He would come into contact with 20 different ones a day, easy.
我一直追问他，但他说是为了这个驼鹿过度浪漫化是一个错误，仅仅因为它有一个有趣的名字。里克认识的驼鹿太多了。他随随便便一天就能接触到20种不同的。
And I realize, he seemed to see each of those animals the way I saw Buzzwinkle-- as an individual. When Rick said Buzzwinkle was no different from other moose, it didn't cheapen Buzzwinkle. It elevated moose.
而且我意识到，他似乎以我看Buzzwinkle的方式看待那些动物中的每一个——作为一个个体。当里克说Buzzwinkle和其他驼鹿没什么不同时，这并没有贬低Buzzwinkle。它提升了驼鹿。
Jon Mooallem. He's a writer at large for the New York Times Magazine and the author of the book, Wild Ones, where, among other things, he writes about a moose that Thomas Jefferson felt a need to send to France.
乔恩·穆艾勒姆。他是《纽约时报杂志》的一名自由撰稿人，也是《野性》一书的作者，书中除了别的事情外，他还写到了托马斯·杰斐逊觉得有必要送往法国的一只驼鹿。
[MUSIC - "ANIMAL - MARK RONSON REMIX" BY MIIKE SNOW]
[音乐 - 米克·斯诺的“Animal - Mark Ronson Remix”]
Well, our show was produced today by Mike Meek, a human being, with our production staff, Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semien, Alyssa Shipp, Matt Tierney, Nancy Updike, and Diane Wu. Our senior producer for today's show is Brian Reed. Our editor for this episode was Joel Lovell. Research help today from Benjamin Anastas and Christopher Swetala. Music help from Damian Graef and Rob Geddis.
好的，我们的节目今天由迈克·米克（一个人类）制作，我们的制作人员还有佐伊·切斯、肖恩·科尔、尼尔·德拉明、斯蒂芬妮·傅、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、罗宾·塞米恩、艾丽莎·希普、马特·蒂尔尼、南希·厄普戴克和黛安·吴。我们今天节目的高级制作人是布莱恩·里德。本集编辑是乔尔·洛弗尔。今天的研究帮助来自本杰明·阿纳斯塔斯和克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉。音乐帮助来自达米安·格拉夫和罗伯·格迪斯。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life was delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, Easter's coming up-- not that far away. But I am not going to give that man another chocolate bunny because the way he eats chocolate bunnies-- it is just too intense.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交换中心）提供给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，复活节快到了——不太远了。但我不会给那个人再买一个巧克力兔子，因为他吃巧克力兔子的方式……实在是太强烈了。
Breaking their legs, biting off their tails, mutilating them in unspeakable ways.
折断它们的腿，咬掉它们的尾巴，以无法形容的方式残害它们。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。